you might know imperial hal for his
incredible highlights
i got one where what are they for i got
another
oh my god you might know him because he
can get a little spicy
and calm i'm pushing come on come on
come with me go with me
i don't yeah this is a better spot i
think
no get the over here right now maybe
he's
not for everyone i can't change that we
play over there early
i can't do hal right now bro like low
key i cannot
like he actually stresses me out i feel
like i'm losing i'm losing life
expectancy
but if you follow apex legends esports
it's fair to say that the reason you
know how
is because he's so good that he's
impossible
to ignore i suck one
oh my god oh my god vaporizer
doesn't want the reds nice tracking very
good damage there
there's a bunch of people here though
smoking might help him
oh beautiful that is excellent
it's not the same person coming in from
below nice stuff there what a response
athleticos neon is going to go down and
albert
is going to finish off not kd as well
and say goodbye to the aussies
after fleeing a failing battle royale
hal became the star of a game that was
struggling for recognition
and he didn't just stand out he exploded
imperial howe is the head clicking [ __ ]
talking leader of tsm's apex legends
team
but this life was never his plan
it was more like a hobby i never really
wanted
it to turn into like a job it was i
didn't like think it would
weren't you playing on some like laptop
that was just i heard your story it was
just oh yeah i used to play with like
on this really bad laptop at first like
in h1z1 yeah
but eventually i was able to go to land
and then i got money from land to buy my
own pc
but it was never like
during my childhood i was like never
like planning on you know playing video
games for a living
that land was the h1z1 elite series in
atlanta
where his team hailed chapters placed
fourth and his performance was enough
for cloud9 to sign him to their h1z1
roster in april 2018.
hal's future seemed bright he was a
young player who just signed with a
major esports orc
but then life threw him a curveball in
the summer of 2018
after just one split the h1z1 pro league
collapsed
an esports career may not have been
hal's goal but after breaking into a
scene
just before it fell apart he started
looking at other games for new
opportunities if you were a battle
royale player in 2018
you had to at least consider fortnite as
an option and
hal did but it didn't exactly work out
and he hasn't really changed his mind
about the game since
hey man i'm so done with this game like
what are you doing how about the chance
to play fortnite duos
at twitchcon in late 2018 and he took it
playing alongside former cloud9 pub g
player frex they took home a 10 000 team
prize for placing the top 64.
but the game that launched how into
stardom was just over the horizon
kodai squad wins again their deaths
still carry honor oh
bastards check out the loot they left
[Music]
gibraltar
uh i i was playing fortnite before apex
so as soon as apex came out i
instantly tried apex and i really liked
the game but i didn't really like
fortnite
so i decided to instantly switch so
that's how i started playing apex apex
legends was part battle royale part hero
shooter
but to how it represented an even
greater opportunity than h1z1
he signed with kim solomon in march 2019
and eventually
he got to have a say on the team's
roster moves reps and albarelli were
soon added to the team at his
recommendation
that you guys have never played with me
before i picked him up i've never talked
to him before i picked up with
before i picked him up i never played
with jordan before i picked him up or
even talked to him
i just messaged jordan like hey want to
join csm
that's actually pretty insane suddenly
after the changes
tsm were unstoppable doesn't want the
reds nice tracking
very good damage there there's a bunch
of people here though but smoke might
help him
oh beautiful that is excellent
which might explain why he's so low on
shotgun ammo at the moment
oh so good telling you man he's got the
best the best part finder movement or
some of the best for sure
what's that sexy part finding me oh
there we go and there is the bounty the
booty
tsm still in this center position they
have been unmatched this whole time
maybe got peppered up a few times
but boy oh boy they look beautiful
imperial hal
finds two in front of him he's gonna
have the r99 shredding through the
shields
here comes the eva eight and it is gonna
do the job
clean up duty and they get a few more
kills in turn
it's not the safest thing coming in from
hello nice stuff there what a response
atletico's neon is going to go down and
albert
is going to finish off not kd as well
and say goodbye to the aussies
only one can get the gold and it's going
to go to none other
than team solomid
[Applause]
esm's rise culminated at the apex
legends pre-season invitational the
first ever international tournament held
by the game's developer
gamer's origin or tsm who will be your
champions
portal out here for tsm five seconds and
counting bravo
let's do this here we go this could be
it two teams on match point here mvp
pushing in
can they get this first knock doesn't
come in russ has to stay alive very low
hp
for the race very early i frame so
that's gonna be a big setback there but
mvp is not the one we're worried about
is there just a setback here
for tsm who is going to do it tsm
you're your champion it took him a while
to get to match point
but in the end they win back to back
apex legend tournaments
your x games winners and your winners of
the apex legends preseason
invitational imperial howe and tsm were
on top of the young apex world
the 100 000 grand prize was a bigger
take than anything hal had
ever seen in his career but the
preseason event gave way to an
unexpected reality the global pandemic
forced the apex legends global series
online for its inaugural season
the algs still went ahead and the only
format allowed players stuck at home to
stream their own pov
this gave them a chance to not only come
into their own as players but
as creators as well pal was immediately
popular
it helped that his team was one of the
best in the world but his popularity
was growing thanks to something else
whether it was from his pov streams in
competitive games or just during his
ranked game streaming in his free time
how's comms could get pretty blunt
myself like what the [ __ ] are you doing
they're coming back come back holy [ __ ]
like why the [ __ ] are you here bro he's
uh very emotional with the game very
emotional
uh if he dies in a really dumb way or
something
we will know about it because he will be
yelling
but while many interpreted his tone as
overly harsh or
even toxic hal didn't see it that way
when you're in igl
and you're like blunt you're just gonna
be normal you're always gonna get call
toxic no matter what
you can't like change that i don't know
how to turn up competitiveness i always
i i every time i play apex i'm
competitive no matter if it's a pub it's
a rank game or whatever the [ __ ] it is
tsm's honeymoon period in late 2019 was
incredible
but by mid-2020 things were starting to
fall apart a bit at big events
after coming into the summer circuit
regional playoffs as the points leader
tsm finished sixth a far cry from the
dominant first place finishes they were
used to
and so in october pal made another
change to the team
after albarelli stepped down hal tapped
snipe down
a storied fps veteran who just made the
jump to apex
snipe was always on his knees for me
after we beat him so he was
next to line he was buttering up he was
pretty good honestly
he was pretty good on his knees so
despite being eight years older than hal
and basically ancient by esports terms
snipe down made
sense he came from the halo scene which
was known for not holding back
if there's one player on eg that you
feel you need to shut down
who is that player probably sniped on
he's like
the best player he's just so sick you
know
i get really worried when i see him and
you know it's just
the stuff he does is insane all right
well uh any any words here snipe down
i remember what happened last time that
exact quote was said to me so uh
watch your face snipe said that no
matter what anyone
said about hal's comb style the
atmosphere on the team
fit him just fine i was drawn to your
guys's team because i felt like you guys
were the only team that had like
the same competitive mindset that i had
brought over and i was like i don't
i want to i want to win and if i don't
win like i'm not
just okay with that and despite
everybody on the team willing to be
completely
brutally honest with each other hal says
that he's learned when to let things go
it doesn't affect me when i get you know
like mad or whatever but it would affect
my teammates
right so it was important for me to you
know
like let them know like you know what
they did wrong but at the same time move
on because oh yeah there's still more
games
to you know play off yeah we got to be
aware of what went wrong and everything
and uh like talk about it but you know
we don't have to talk about it for
30 minutes and then still going into the
next game like you got to move on
tsm improved to third at the autumn na
super regional
and whether the fans thought hal was
toxic or not just didn't matter to the
new roster
but that didn't mean the issue went away
at the second week of the na winter
circuit
howe's comms were singled out by algs
caster t-squared as
being the opposite of constructive well
it happened last game where
protectful and his team went over
towards fragment and they ended up
killing tsm
and i wanted to go tune into howell's
stream to see exactly what was happening
and the communication was completely
different than what was going on
with complexity where they're talking
about things being positive
et cetera it was more how just kind of
yelling at his teammates and being like
how do we lose this or i understand the
competitiveness about it but
you can't go through and you know ego
charge these teams over towards fragment
side yes
it sucks that protectables teams going
and dropping over there
it sucks even worse that you just lost
your 50 50 because now they're gonna
continue to drop there they're gonna
continue to add the pressure on
and you gotta feel bad for a player like
reps who probably didn't want to take
that fight to begin with
and you don't really hear much
communication going on between ts and
when you compare it to a team like
complexities
and while the two exchanged words on
twitter afterwards this issue
again raised the question of whether or
not hal is driven
or just toxic as long as hal remains his
outspoken self
and has teammates willing to embrace the
criticism and speak their own minds as
well
it seems like the discussion is just
gonna keep going
whether you love how or not it's hard to
deny that the combination of his
attitude
and his results are what make him one of
the most exciting players in apex
i don't play other games in apex other
than apex
i do not go to school i literally all i
do chat is
i wake up you know do the morning
routine
get on and play apex being good at the
game is important
another third place finish at the 2021
alg sna championship showed that tsm is
still hanging with the game's best
but tsm kind of just watching everything
go down how managed to get a stick there
onto bronzy as well as now letter e are
gonna make their move the bubble goes
down the ultimate goes down from the
core stick
keeping our eye on the feed as these
teams fight as snipe down is brought
back into the game
he's only got an heirloom to work with
but snipe down still trying to do what
he could do
he got two kills with the airloom but
he's going to go down and the rest of
dsm is all down to rent and reps goes
off
but the only thing better than being
amazing at a game
is having a unique style and approach
that gets people talking about you
put the ball on your playmaker's hand
and let him make the plays in the late
game when it matters the most aka
imperial hal one of the best if not
arguably the best
in the world to do it apex legends is
gonna be moving back to lan in the near
future
and hal is one of the stars that a new
crop of aspiring players are gonna be
looking up to
because in the cutthroat world of battle
royales how is a reminder that no matter
what people say about you
whether or not they call you toxic being
deeply competitive
is still a path to success if you ever
want to get better
just play how i do play like you have no
care you want to push everybody
play solo pubs try to 1v3 that's how you
get better
[Music]
pokemon go 2018 is a little late for
pokemon go to want somebody to start him
that was like 2016 right
wonder pokemon what was the summer of
pokemon go i feel like that was 2016 or
2017
july 6 2016. that wasn't pokemon go came
out
no it was also big the next summer but
that first summer was absolute peak i
remember man it was
crazy in toronto